it's the worst unrest south africa has
seen
in years in the city of durban shops
have been looted
and warehouses set on fire some of the
area's wealthier residents have
reportedly chartered planes
for helicopters and left
but others like okay can't afford to
leave
his car dealership in johannesburg was
destroyed
one of hundreds of businesses targeted
by looters
now he has no money to support his
family or
to pay his 16 employees my livelihood
has been taken away from me
in my eyes i was sitting crying helpless
because i can't do anything
the vandalism is overwhelming for the
shop owner
she was planning on retiring from her
party supply store
now she must start over why
i'm 55 years old retirement is here
i put everything into my business
everything i've got nothing no pension
money nothing
with police often outnumbered some
locals have created their own vigilante
groups by stopping looters to protect
their properties
looting has hit supply chains across the
country
disrupting transportation services and
manufacturing
food medicine and fuel supplies are
running short
amid fears of violence these customers
are not allowed into this market
they must buy their food through a
window gap
what began as protests against the
arrest of ex-president jacob zuma last
week
escalated to riots with a 32 percent
unemployment rate
the unrest is also magnifying south
africa's poverty and inequality
27 years after the end of apartheid
i stole a few things like cold drinks
and electrical appliances
as well as some paint i guess the real
reason is because we have
nothing when you see other people
stealing at some point you realize that
shops will close
and you will be left with nothing so you
ask yourself after all of this
how will i survive with the way things
are
as calls to end looting and violence go
unheard
many fear the unrest may lead to
unprecedented economic damage
katya lopez al jazeera